yeah like i feel like tyron if you spoke
to him and you had like a conversation
he'd probably have like cool stories
like interesting fight stuff background
he's probably like a good guy
but in terms of like raw entertainment
value and like a press conference
he's he's not interesting
right one to one probably [ __ ]
amazing
right raw entertainment
not bringing it right i don't think
there's a lot of curiosity about this
fight
and i think that jake picked the wrong
opponent yeah jake's gonna have to carry
this [ __ ] promotion he's crazy i
think he underestimated how much ben
askren did to help
ben was amazing in the build-up of that
fight
because he's an incredibly entertaining
character whether you like him or not
he's entertaining
i was definitely more intrigued when i
saw that little thing where he shoved
ben and ben like slapped his face or
whatever it was touched you know i mean
like that
made me talking [ __ ] like dude are you
jealous of your brother
i would end you in a street fight
whatever he said i would commit a
homicide like
all that [ __ ] that made me more
interested in this fight this tyrant
woodley fight
i'm curious but i'm not like i gotta buy
it i'll buy it
to talk about it here but i don't i mean
all i'm saying is like jake's gonna have
to work double time
yeah like he's already doing the thing
with the tattoo he's like the loser gets
the other person's
name tattooed on their body i mean
there's great stakes with that i didn't
bet that
[Laughter]
that's such a good bet though the stakes
are good yeah but will you pay the
pay-per-view
to see if he gets a tattoo or will you
just go oh okay one of them won i'll see
the i'll go on instagram and watch the
tattoo
that exactly i i i don't think tyron
is interesting enough to where i want to
see him either beat jake paul
or jake paul beat him and i think jake
is in this interesting space where like
because he's won a few of these fights
he's actually becoming likable
he's no longer really the underdog
either like yeah you're looking at him
being like oh yeah he
probably should be tyrant yeah but now
we believe he's good i'm looking at him
he looks way bigger
he looks like a tiger looks stronger we
believe he can hit allah had a good
point like he's been training as a boxer
for the last four years that's it and
tyron's been rapping
yeah like doing other [ __ ] doing mma
stuff kind of wrestling like
yeah that kind of stuff's not helping
you when you're getting the ring so now
we're like we believe in jake's ability
and there's a like ability attached to
it because we're like yo this guy who is
like the disney star punk
is actually about that life yeah he can
go up yeah
right so now the desire to see the
disney star kid
get beaten up is limited
and the desire to watch the opponent
fight at
all is non-existent so where's the
interest in the fight
yeah like if if it was nate diaz
fighting jake
i mean you just love nate so much like
all right nate shut the kid up
yeah but now i think a lot of people
don't like tyron
i think more people like jake than tyron
that is not the fighter that you want to
fight yeah
jake is amazing at garnering interest on
the internet and being
like uh unlikable a troll right
he's amazing at getting people to go
[ __ ] jake paul and you're signing up
because you want to see him get knocked
out
he's better as a heel and that's good
way better way to say he's better as a
heel and he's positioned himself as the
face
yeah and it's not even his liking he
doesn't even want to be the face i don't
think
but i think that tyron has such a lack
of interest yeah
that it leaves jake as the face of the
fight
yeah i i don't know man do you have any
do you guys have interest in it
when they announced the fight i had no
interest in yeah i had no interest in it
and tyron's not if you if you're a heel
you need a hero tyler's not a great hero
that's the thing he's he seems cool but
i'm not like [ __ ] let's go i would
i don't know him to have a big fan
following when he fought ufc even now
that was a big issue with the ufc is
that people didn't want to watch him
fight they thought the fights were
boring
so now you're looking at a guy who
wasn't a hero and now we have to kind of
make him the hero
and then all the heal stuff from jake
because he's getting a little funnier
and less heal-ish
less hate-able so the emotion's not
there the draw is not there yeah i think
they're just looking at us like a
stepping stone where they go like
he's gotta win we can lose this he's
[ __ ] right but if he's like if we can
beat
like this likely beatable ufc champ a
former ufc champ
like that puts you now at the next you
beat a ufc guy now you beat a ufc champ
and i think that just opens up the
staircase i'm sure they have a whole
like they have their whole chronicle of
how they want it to go i think
okay so then maybe you take a little bit
of a now on this i mean i just don't see
it
i mean look jake has a way of
galvanizing the internet he'll find ways
to make the
thing most likely but on his face
if he doesn't get if he doesn't win this
fight he's [ __ ] if he wins this fight
the next one will probably be bigger
because he got this under his belt but
my feeling doesn't matter who he fought
the next one's gonna be bigger
just make sure you engage with people
that are engaging dude jake paul versus
nick diaz right now would be
[ __ ] insane yeah but like if he keeps
on knocking out like former nba guys
like that just gets old it's like all
right
yeah you can beat up the guys that
depending how invested we are on those
people
like we're really invested in those
people if he plays alan
really yeah if he's fighting someone
that we love if he fights allen iverson
you don't think [ __ ] are tuning
into that [ __ ] that's why i wish they
should just keep it celebrity boxing
yeah like but he'll just take the [ __ ]
out of celebrities he'll beat the [ __ ]
out of celebrities but celebrities will
talk more like they'll make it more like
it'd be fun
yeah that's a great point the reason why
the celebrity box is interesting is
because they know how to entertain
yeah yeah they know how to build up the
fight the crossover is the fighter who
can entertain
yeah that's the crosstalk that's why he
wants connor so badly yeah
my suspicion is i think he's trying to
pivot into like a legit boxing career
yeah yeah or at least like semi-legit
and like try to get like a prize fight
with like canelo or
like floyd or some [ __ ] i don't think he
wants a legit prize fight you don't
think so
and i think they're too many years i
think he's just canelo will
[ __ ] him up he started too late yeah i
think he started too late to fight the
elite of elites
i don't think he started too late to
fight mma guys that learned how to
strike
around his age as well right because a
career wrestler yeah that learned how to
strike when they're 22 years old or
something like that when they entered
mma or something he learned
exactly it's basically what he was doing
so now you want to level playing field
right um but i i think he's going for
like a big pay-per-view fight it's a
conor thing or
yeah somebody else who who um is a
massive star
in the fight in fight sports but not
necessarily
uh qualified
as an elite boxer yeah i don't think you
want to do that
i think adrian broner that'd be the best
one i mean that'd be hilarious
that'd be so much fun the build-up would
be
unbelievable yeah that'd be great real
talk yeah we don't
have a chat yeah oh i think he's too big
for adrian
oh okay but i mean because adrian's tiny
adrian's 100
is tinier than floyd smaller than floyd
yes
yes i thought he was bigger than him no
adrian fought between like 135 i think i
think he'll put on weight
like floyd walks around his fight weight
correct me if i'm wrong adrian seems
like he'll put on some weight so he'll
look bigger and then for the fight he'll
be
fighting maybe like he don't carry he
doesn't stay in shape all year long
well he gets fat yeah but like adrian is
smaller than floyd
yeah and that said fight smaller i want
to say it nicer but yeah he gets fat
in between fights floyd doesn't floyd
stays in shape yeah that [ __ ] would be
entertaining yeah
for real that's the fight yeah he'll
find something
because we don't want to see adrian
fight boxers anymore and just keep
getting beat up
just end up fighting these celebs that'd
be great yeah
adrian got to get into the celeb boxing
[Applause]
yeah